Hey, welcome to the explainer. This is
where we take really big, sometimes
complicated ideas and well, we break
them down into frameworks you can
actually use. So, today we're going to
unpack something really interesting.
It's pharmacist Ben Future's whole
philosophy on why we get sick and more
importantly, his unified strategy for
health. We're going to start with a
frustration I think a lot of us share.
Then, we'll travel upstream to what he
says are the real root causes and
finally we'll look at his big picture
solution. All right, let's dive right
in. And we're going to start with a
feeling that, well, it's something a lot
of us know all too well. It's that
feeling of being caught in a frustrating
cycle, especially if you're dealing with
a chronic health issue. You know the
drill, right? You're bouncing from one
specialist to the next just trying to
get some answers. I mean, it seems like
the logical thing to do, doesn't it?
You've got an issue with a specific part
of your body, so you go see the doctor
who specializes in exactly that part.
But here's where pharmacist Ben Fuches
throws a wrench in the works. He asks a
really critical question. What if this
superfocused approach, this this laser
focus is actually making us miss the
bigger picture entirely? So, you know,
an eye problem, off you go to the
opthalmologist, a heart issue, and bam,
you're seeing a cardiologist and you
know, a skin thing pops up. So, it's a
visit to the dermatologist. And look,
each of these experts is doing their
job, right? They're diligently tackling
their one specific piece of the puzzle.
But here's the kicker. According to
Fuks, this whole fragmented approach, it
completely misses the point. He argues
that all of these separate diverse
symptoms, you know, from your kidneys to
your skin to whatever else, they aren't
separate problems at all. They're just
different branches on the same dying
tree. They're all signs of one single
systemic issue that he pretty bluntly
calls MBFA disease or my body is falling
apart disease. Okay. So if chasing down
each individual symptom isn't the
answer, then what is? Well, this is
where Fuk says we need to adopt a
totally new first principle. And this
right here, this is his core idea. He
says where you see the problem is not
where the problem begins. The symptom
you're looking at is just a signal. The
real cause that's located upstream. So
what does he actually mean by going
upstream? Well, it's pretty simple,
really. It means you have to trace that
symptom, whatever it is, all the way
back to its true origin. And Fox argues
that this journey, it almost always
leads you back to the body's main
operating systems, your digestion and
your metabolism. But he's really clear
on one point, the digestive system, it's
not just another part to look at. He
says it is the root system. It's the
soil that your entire health grows out
of. Okay? So, let's actually follow that
stream, right? Let's go upstream. The
first major system we hit is the blood.
And according to folks, the blood can
become well a literal highway for
toxicity. His claim is this. All disease
is cell disease. It all starts at the
cellular level. And why do cells get
sick? Because of what the blood delivers
to them, or just as important, what it
fails to deliver. So folks points a
finger at two main culprits that make
our blood dirty as he calls it. First
up, you've got a compromised gut. You've
probably heard the term leaky gut, and
that's when stuff that's supposed to
stay in your digestive system leaks out
into your bloodstream. Not good. And the
second big one, high blood sugar. He
says sugar acts like a toxin that
literally makes your blood thick and
sludgy. And that sludgy blood is a major
driver of inflammation all over the
body. And this is where a really
dangerous chain reaction kicks off. This
toxic, sludgy blood, it just can't do
its job right. It can't deliver oxygen
and nutrients the way it's supposed to.
So what happens? Your organs start to
get starved and at the same time they're
getting poisoned. And that just leads to
this massive cascade of problems
everywhere in the body. This brings us
to a really powerful analogy he uses.
Fox calls our circulatory system the
railroad of toxicity. Just picture it.
This dirty, sludgy blood is like a train
chugging through your entire body and
it's making stops at every single
station. The heart, the brain, the skin,
you name it. And at every single stop,
it's dropping off a little toxic
package. Okay, so we've talked about the
blood, but if we go even further
upstream, there's another absolutely
critical area, the very structure that
literally holds our body together. We're
talking about connective tissue. And
this is where he really, I mean, really
flips the script on how we think about
aging. He takes all these common
conditions and reframes them as just a
breakdown of this one thing, connective
tissue. I mean, think about this for a
second. Glaucoma, he says, that's not
just an eye problem. It's osteoporosis
of the eye. Wrinkles on your skin,
that's osteoporosis of the skin. All of
a sudden, you see, it's all pointing
back to the same fundamental mechanism.
And the way he describes his connective
tissue is it's just incredible. It's not
just some boring passive scaffolding
holding you up. No, he calls it the goo
and the glue of the body. It's the jell-
mold that gives your organs their shape
and holds them in place. And get this,
he even calls it the womb for every
single cell, the very matrix that
nurtures them. This all leads him to
coin this amazing and kind of funny term
for what we see as aging. He calls it
blobification. You know that sagging,
that loss of firmness and structure that
we all notice over time. He says at its
core, that's just blobification. It's
the physical sign that our vital
connective tissue is breaking down.
Okay. So if the big root problems are
dirty blood and deteriorating connective
tissue, what do we do about it? What's
the solution? Well, Fuches proposes a
unified strategy that goes right after
these root causes. So you can forget the
old idea of a specific pill for a
specific ill. His solution is a
multi-pronged approach that's all about
restoring the body's foundation. It
means you stop chasing symptoms and you
start focusing on the real stuff. You
focus on fixing the gut to clean up the
blood at the source. You work on
controlling your blood sugar to get rid
of that toxic sludge. You use strategic
supplements to literally rebuild that
connective tissue. You improve
oxygenation and that can be as simple as
deep breathing. And finally, you help
your entire system detoxify itself. And
this right here really captures that
fundamental shift in thinking. The
standard medical model often feels like
you're just treating the rotten fruit on
the tree. You're focused on the symptom.
This systemic model, it's about ignoring
the fruit for a second, getting down on
your hands and knees and focusing all of
your energy on nourishing the roots of
the tree. And that really is the crucial
takeaway from all this. Once you start
to understand these upstream mechanisms,
your whole role can shift. You go from
being a passive patient, you know, just
receiving treatments to becoming an
active, empowered participant in your
own health story. So ultimately, this
whole framework challenges us to ask a
new question. What if that problem
you're dealing with isn't the problem at
all? What if it's just a signal, a
message from your body inviting you to
look deeper, to go upstream, and to
finally find the true underlying cause?